you know this is actually a good kind of
metaphor that he's he's talking about
right here like usually he kind of goes
off the rails and it doesn't make sense
but I'm like that one made sense I make
a lot of sense y'all just too dumb to
understand
[Music]
so this has been kind of making its way
around the news happy Los Angeles
anybody recognize this right here oh you
made a tiny house right he did dude the
homeless people here are living large
you get points dude you get you how does
everybody feel about that you get to
keep it that's better than tense I'd
rather have that than all the tents is
it on Wheels it's on Wheels it's
transportable wow and this came as a
result because the city would continue
to come up to him and tell him to remove
or take down his tent after a while he's
like well I can't keep on taking down my
tent so we decided to build a house wow
wow and technically he can keep it up by
way of uh city codes if
transients homeless peoples did it clean
like that
I'll be perfectly supporting them a
thousand percent really in front of your
business though but on streets if
there's a bunch of tiny homes on the
sidewalks yep but what if it's like a
drug dealing Den well is it clean yeah
it's fine it's got to be clean it's got
to be clean one of my buddies he's a
he's a commercial real estate guy and he
manages some property and pasting him
somewhere and he says there's this
homeless guy that stays in the back
and they keep them there because he
keeps all the other crazy homeless dudes
off his block hey he protects he's like
the enforcer he's the enforcer so he's
like hey you better not kick it over
here they need him they need him and
they're like they have a relationship
with them and he's like yeah bro those
dudes were tripping over here we got rid
of them blah blah blah so I'm like hey
sometimes it works out I mean if you
could have that that's amazing that's
[ __ ] best case scenario it's the
ecosystem yeah that's rare as [ __ ] why
that doesn't normally happen because
they usually tell their friends to come
over and then it becomes a [ __ ] but this
guy's a staple the community everyone
gives them free food they give them free
coffee they hook him up and he's just
like he's living the one by my studio
which was like half a block long it just
kept growing those dudes were just steal
[ __ ] from Cars yeah they're constantly
because they don't have a regulator
so most places don't that homeless guy
he's like the neighborhood cat that
everybody likes to feed and they'll
catch the rat they'll catch the bad [ __ ]
you know like that's what you need yeah
you can't have a bunch of straight cats
just [ __ ] up your [ __ ] right you
gotta you gotta have the neighborhood
cat that everybody loves you know this
is actually a good kind of metaphor that
he's he's talking about right here like
usually he kind of goes off the rails
and it doesn't make sense but I'm like
that one made sense yeah you're a cat
guy you're a cat I make a lot of sense
y'all just too dumb to understand
[Laughter]
the problem they have the neighborhood
cat too and this neighborhood cat is
stealing everyone's bikes and car parts
that's not the Beloved cat that's the
Stray Cat I'm talking about you when you
have too many Stray Cats that's what
[ __ ] it up and this cat also brings a
bunch of other cats over the point is
the cat only works if there's a rat
problem do you have a rat problem well
they always have a rap problem it's just
these homies want to fight the other
homies so they're just like homeless
gangs now and then they brings up a cat
still they put music in the middle of
the night with all his other cats
[ __ ] having a cat party at like 3 A.M
like cat party yeah and I'm like man
they need to do something this guy's
being used as like the flagship uh
example of being offered housing and a
bunch of things and he's just like no
thanks yeah and then they're like okay
bye and they just like so is he
considered unhoused anymore yeah but
they're they tried to give him all the
things he's entitled to in terms of like
how the city will help you and he just
declined it and that's it you know I was
I was listening to a little bit of this
particular topic uh when it was Joe
Rogan and and Dave Chappelle was talking
about this exact same thing right and so
obviously on the one hand you've got
this like well if you've got like the
mental ability and capability and the
talent to put something like this
together it's like apply that to maybe
anything and not necessarily need to be
homeless they don't want to a lot of
people want to be off the bridge exactly
so so there's like that conversation and
then on the empathetic side they were
actually talking about like the idea of
um imagine getting these Housing
Services but then it's like hey you can
live in this spot for whatever because
you get like unhoused services but maybe
but no pets allowed and maybe their only
relationship that they actually have is
like with their straight pet you know
what I'm saying tough luck homie you
broke Beggars can't be choosers and
you're a beggar right now but just the
idea of that well the irony is like they
might not necessarily be begging for
that situation they might be down to to
live that life like like bar said they
might be okay living off the grid yeah
and then at the end of the day like this
system this imaginary system that we've
created called Society like all these
people are on the on the outsides of it
and they probably just don't want to be
a part of this program that we're all in
and I mean I get it like when you are
like a different example would be like
let's say you have a criminal record and
you are just trying to [ __ ] be a
decent part of you know human life and
like you're trying to work all the jobs
you get is like real shitty and you want
to maybe progress and all that stuff but
you have that record you can't get a
decent job you got that stain on your on
your record you can't make the money
that you used to make before let's say
if you're like a really successful
criminal and you're making like you know
tens of thousands of dollars every day
and then all of a sudden you go back to
doing minimum wage and working with
people that just you know are so
disrespectful to you your status is low
again like wouldn't you want to go back
to something where you feel like the man
again like I would if I was a big time
drug dealer and then all of a sudden I'm
like this low-level person and
everyone's like really an ass to me and
treated me like dirt I'd be like [ __ ]
this world like [ __ ] this system I'm
gonna go back to being illegal again
like I don't know and then not not that
I absolutely condone it but I can
understand the psychology behind it if
you're given a choice it is like even we
understand this right we work
so hard being a good student doing what
you're supposed to do and you get a
nine-to-five job and then somehow it
just doesn't really work out or or the
company goes under and then like you get
bad luck and you're like I did
everything right that I was supposed to
do I followed What Society told me to do
and then it still [ __ ] [ __ ] up for
me oh [ __ ] maybe I should have just done
whatever I wanted not not that it you
know not not if it was I mean not saying
that it's illegal there's a positive way
to say the exact same thing you just
said though to be honest you know what I
mean like in the sense where I would
condone that
um the idea that everybody who follows
the system you're still at risk for
failing in some way you're still at risk
for something not working in your favor
or running into like you said just bad
luck so it could happen to anybody take
the risk to do something non-hornful
anyway you know what I mean is the the
bright side to that element I think Dr
Phil had a really good thing that he
said about this specific dude and he was
saying that like when you look at this
guy he has some skills in crafting like
you can do things but the system in
place doesn't have a tailored thing for
a guy with his skills it has things for
just everyone with no skills so like if
he wants to live in a home and be on the
track he's got to get rid of all his
possessions because you can't there's
nowhere to put it so then he's back to
just being a regular homeless guy and
not like a homeless guy with a specific
thing that they can nurture so that's
where Dr Phil's like no the system is
just making everybody blanks yeah yeah
and that's why it's hard for guys to get
a leg up when they actually can do
something yeah he has talent and and he
can't thrive in the structure that he's
right because maybe if he was in not in
La he could be a Craftsman what if he
was in like the Woods by himself like
what's the difference between that and
this well that's that's one thing that I
think is pretty kind of dumb like
because homeless people a lot of them
came here because the laws allowed them
to exist a lot easier than it does in
other communities but also this is
[ __ ] hard mode like California is the
hardest place to even go from A to B let
alone go from like all the way at the
bottom to something livable right like
we're having a hard time just being
normal people like you said 60k a year
yeah and you're still struggling yeah so
people making 100K a year they're still
like [ __ ] so it to me I think it's a
fault of the state to make such lacks
laws for homeless people in a place
where economically it's hard to thrive
yeah those two things that go together
no like don't make this the easiest
place to be homeless and the hardest
place to have a home like that's so
weird yeah it's like hey you want to
learn how to swim this is a 20-foot
swimming pool
can we start with
like if you want to even get out of
homelessness it's like okay a tank of
gas or something [ __ ] eight dollars
in downtown you know you're like what
the [ __ ] yeah
yeah let's create a situation where
there's a huge like rich and poor
population in La feels like that because
to do everything the right way like
let's say own a home
um you know and and live like like in a
nice neighborhood and all that right and
and follow all the laws you actually
have to have a ton of [ __ ] money or
your family had to be here for so many
generations and they passed down the
house yeah if you're like a new
immigrant or you come from lower income
like it's really [ __ ] hard to get out
of your neighborhood and buy a decent
home because now the average house is
like almost a mill here yeah and not
even being like an immigrant or having
you know not as fortunate about
upbringing even for normal people you
know growing up in the suburbs in
Wisconsin I come out here and you know
it's hard especially for Our Generation
everything's so expensive a middle class
person from Wisconsin coming here is
like a poor immigrant
[Laughter]
man like outside of California damn and
yeah in California the average is like
800 Grand so like hey after it dipped
after yeah yeah that's the Low by the
way but that's almost three times the
value so like if you're from any other
state and you come to California that's
three times that you have to have a
better job all that [ __ ] so it's like
why I will say though if I was homeless
I'd probably come to California and I it
has nothing to do with just the last
it's also like the weather if I'm gonna
be like sleeping outside if you're gonna
survive the winter yeah I remember uh
like hearing about like homeless people
like in New York and stuff and sometimes
it would just free they would just
freeze in the night and you know police
just got to pick up dead bodies well if
you could build like that you build like
a shelter in Alaska yeah build a cool
cabin Igloo yeah you just build the
igloo that's exactly where you want to
be building igloos then how hard is it
to live in Alaska it's pretty chill
salmon everywhere oh yeah
it's pretty chill there's salmon
everywhere
[Music]
[Music]